so right over here we have graph we have
a graph the graph of the function y is
equal to X to the three halves power and
what I want to do is find the arc length
of this curve but when from when x
equals zero to when X is equal 2 and I'm
going to pick a strange number here and
I picked the strange number because it
makes the numbers work out very well 2x
is equal to 32 over 9 32 over 9 is let's
see that's a it's a three and three and
five ninths so it's going to be right
around so that's three and a half so
it's going to be a little bit past three
and a half so it's going to be like
right over there so we want to find we
want to find this this arc length right
over here this thing that I have
depicted in yellow so it's from 0 to 32
over nine and I encourage you to pause
the video and try this out on your own
so I'm assuming you've had a go at it if
any point while I'm working through it
you feel inspired always feel free to
pause the video and continue working
with it so let's just apply the arc
length formula that we got kind of a
conceptual proof for in the previous
video so we know that the arc length let
me write this the arc length is going to
be equal to the definite integral from 0
to 32 over 9 of the square root actually
let me let me just write it in general
terms first so that you can kind of see
the formula then how we apply it so it's
the square root of 1 plus f prime of x
squared DX and in this case that's going
to be it's going to be the definite
integral from 0 to 32 over 9 ty of I
should say the square root of 1 plus now
what's the derivative if f of X if f of
X is x to the three-halves then f prime
of x is going to be 3 has X to the 1/2
and we picked this
this particular function because it
simplifies quite well when we put it
under the radical it's it's fairly
straightforward to find the
antiderivative so we've done a lot of
engineering of this problem to make the
numbers work out well but let's just go
through it so this is f prime of X F
prime of x squared is going to be this
quantity squared it's going to be 9 over
4 X to the 1/2 squared is X so 1 plus
9/4 X DX and so now we just have a
definite integral that we have we know
how to solve this type of thing and you
might be able to even do this in your
head
essentially you do the u substitution
and say ok I have 1 plus 9/4 X its
derivative is 9/4 i can kind of engineer
that if i want but instead i'm just
going to do straight up use u
substitution so use substitution so if i
say u is equal to 1 plus 9 over 4x and
then we know let's see d u DX would be d
u DX is going to be equal to 9/4 or we
could say D U is equal to 9/4 DX or we
could say DX or we could say let me
scroll down a little bit we could say DX
is equal to I'm just going to multiply
both times both sides times 4/9 is equal
to 4/9 D U and then we just have to
change the bounds of integration when X
is equal to when X is equal to 0 then U
is going to be equal to 9 4 times 0 is 2
0 so U is going to be equal to 1 and
when X is equal to 32 over 9 32 over 9
and this is why that number was picked
what's you going to be equal to 32 over
9 times 9 4 is going to be 32 over 4
which is going to be 8 plus 1 so that
worked out very nicely imagine that so
there you have it so this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
the definite integral actually let me
make it clear this is what is equal to
this the definite integral from U is
equal to U is equal to 1/2 U is equal to
9
to make it very explicit that I'm
dealing with you now of the square root
of u instead of DX we have DX is 4/9 D
you let me do it this way
square root whoops that's not the right
color square root of U instead of DX we
have times 4/9 D U and I'm just going to
take the 4/9 and stick it out here 4/9 D
u and we know how to we know how to
apply the fundamental or the SEC is the
second fundamental theorem of calculus
here to to evaluate this definite
integral this is going to be four ninths
times the antiderivative of U of the
square root of u which is the same thing
as u to the one-half is going to be u to
the three-halves and then we divide by
three halves which is the same thing as
multiplying by two thirds and we're
going to evaluate that at U equals nine
and U is equal to one and so we're in
the homestretch here this is going to be
equal to 4/9 times times let's see two
thirds times 9 to the three-halves minus
2/3 times 1 to the 3 half so 9 to the
three-halves that is let's see the
square root of 9 is 3 to the third power
is 27 and this of course is 1 so we are
left with 2/3 of actually let's just
factor out the 2/3 this makes it easier
so we're going to have to be left with
this is going to be equal to 2/3 times
4/9 is is equal to 8 over 27 I've just
factored out the 2/3 and then we're
gonna have 27 minus 1 inside I guess you
could say the brackets now so 27 minus 1
is just going to be 26 it's going to be
26 times 26 and we could obviously we
could simplify this more if we want we
could live whatever 8 times 26 is
so actually let's just let's just figure
that out just for fun so eight times 26
is going to be so this is going to be
160 plus 8 times 6 is 48 so it's 208 208
over 27 and we are and we are done